no no
finally was i turned on no but did i go
yuck yuck
[Music]
okay guys what's up what'd it do it's
monday
um monday fun day
20th we're feeling good on the back end
of september
everything's going well man next week
will be two years yes
we're nine days away from the two year
mark nine days away from two yeah guys
crazy bro
september 29th 2019 we started this
journey
and nearly there on two year mark and it
just feels like well i think we said
this on the live feels i've been doing
this forever but it also feels like we
haven't liked it because we're so in it
we're in this podcasting world every day
we think about every day we try and
improve it every day
we know we don't really take the time to
like step out of our bubble and look at
what we've achieved you know bro it's
hard sometimes it is very difficult plus
i don't like to self-congratulate either
so i just look to just keep it stepping
you always want to improve your zone
yeah yeah yeah well whatever we achieve
now it's never going to be good enough
you're always looking at the next thing
always looking the next thing like the
goals this goal needs to be ticked off
that goal needs to be ticked off so yeah
man i do hear you like same prime
example was um
when we did the
the spotify charts thing the other day
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i looked it and
i was like gang but at no point was i
like
[ __ ] hell like if you would have told
me two years ago like give it two years
you'll be like top 30 yeah yeah yeah in
the in the country i would have taken
that i was taking a run with it in the
chat
what are you sure no not us no never
that fam now
i'm ready and i was like cool
where's that what's that top 10 saying
if this is what 30 feels like what's top
10 what's that top 15 what's that top 10
that's what i'm trying to smell yeah
yeah i sat in it for like four seconds
and then just moved on
in the glory of the top whatever
um
but yeah it's uh
it's cool i need to check it today
actually does it so is it you checking i
thought they sent you emails
ah say no more i thought they sent you
like a because you know how you should
do every month they send us our like
this one yeah i thought that's what they
said yeah they don't send it just goes
on because i never so basically with the
stats and stuff i never i really checked
the stats anyway but um
obviously for
um
thingy purposes
uh sponsorship purposes they ask
yourself oh yeah of course um and
i never i never check them so they asked
for like spotify stats so when i logged
in to check what they were mm-hmm and
then it has like your chart position in
there oh so i could have been checking
it every day um we could have been
number three at one point i don't know
does it show you does it only show you
where you are it doesn't show you it
doesn't say where you've been at but no
no no no that's not what i was gonna say
does it show you where everyone else is
at no it just shows you just as you
you're okay okay okay it showed you
exactly what i showed you that's what i
showed you okay nothing else okay
um
but yeah and then obviously i logged in
yesterday was it was when we posted ting
what we were like 29th
uh absolutely i think we're like 29. i
can't remember and then when i checked
yesterday we were 21st
because i remember seeing the second one
i think the one in the uk because it was
comedy
it was like 88 yeah so yeah comedy was
29.
podcast in total was 88 yeah and then
yesterday
21 21 55 59 59 yeah that's
i was in excel that's a good excel yeah
um
but yeah um guys i hope you're well
let's just get straight into it man
[ __ ] now what's the fun facts
um this one's actually a decent one
today um it's about
the simpsons okay
um so obviously everyone knows that matt
groening is the one that um started the
simpsons and blah blah blah but um did
you know
that the simpsons was based on his
immediate family oh really did you know
who is he bar
who is he
let me speak maggie
let me speak bro
so in 1987 matt groening sketched a
cartoon of his own family and presented
it to fox 34 years
and he's presented to fox 34 years on
the simpson franchise is now worth 10
billion dollars is one of the longest
running tv series ever and has several
income streams merchandise adverts video
games apps or app games rather a movie
books and a theme park [ __ ] theme
park theme park yes
i'm sure it's in disneyland disney world
disney world yeah i've been there i'm
sure it's in disney world yeah yeah um
all while still maintaining high viewers
viewership levels over the years
groaning is now worth several 750
million dollars and the simpson
franchise is one of the highest value tv
franchises in all in all of history and
it's all based on his actual family so
abe simpson
is abram groning his actual grandfather
he's actual pops rather yeah yeah he's
dad yeah he's homer wait wait hold on oh
no that's his grandfather yeah okay so
his grandfather so granddad is his
granddad his granddaddy's his granddad
homer groening is actually homer j
simpson
so his father's name was actually homer
yeah
um marge simpson his actual mother
margaret wiggum yeah
um he's bart
margaret wiggum margaret wiggum was his
mom is his mum's name just like officer
wigan
that's definitely got the name
good point
um matt is bart
um lisa groening is his sister lisa
simpson
margaret groaning his other sister
maggie simpson
his other sister patricia groening is is
there
aunt um
yeah what's it uh
i can't remember what is it oh come here
bucket
selma
patty and selma maybe i think
oh yeah
but yeah it's his other sister so he's
all based on his face and then obviously
from there he's actually split
personality or something
do you think oh because he did it
because he did twins
that's a good thought actually
that's a very good thought bipolar thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but yeah man it's all based on his
whole family or he's a whole immediate
that's sick that's crazy right that's
very cool and it's one of the biggest
franchises in like i was gonna say it
says one of the longest running shows of
all time fam 34
years what other show has been running
longer than that um
probably
wwf wwe
uh yeah i know it's not in like the same
ball yeah
kind of thing
i know that's that's been going on for
decades probably like countdown
count down wow countdown countdown has
been yeah yeah yeah uh
what can we actually google like
jeopardy them kind of old game shows
their game shows run for forever so let
me google top 10 longest-running tv
shows yeah yeah
oh well let me see if i can guess one
uh
tv shows
there we go
i'm saying jeopardy's got to be in there
or like family for is it family fortune
no this can't be right well what's it
saying um they're saying uh simpsons is
number one but i don't think this is in
any specific order by saying this up
there so simpson south park family guy
gunsmoke this is definitely just america
or like american tv shows not like just
shows in general
um
lassie never heard of you've never heard
of lassie the dog
maybe i have but i didn't maybe i didn't
really know his tv show
lassie
i didn't know it was a tv show but
um happy days general hospital
friends yeah these shows aren't running
anymore exactly that's what i'm saying
it's not it's a bit it's a bit skeptical
so i'm gonna try and find it's probably
we're probably basing it on um
if that's the case the simpsons would be
way up there
because obviously friends ran for 10
seasons yeah um south parks on season
like 20 something
they've been going for um
trying to find tv shows so i'm on
wikipedia now the longest one is saying
the championship wimbledon woman's been
going on for 77 years
oh it didn't bring up the information i
was looking for i thought it was going
to be juicy
but anyway yeah that's crazy that is
based on
his immediate family
smart as well though [ __ ] um that's
sick
that's very sick it is it's cool that's
visionary
um i've got like a kind of controversial
statement i've been sitting on it all
week okay i need to get off my chest
okay
how long are we going to pretend that
black man time is not the real thing
how long are we going to play this
who's pretending
white people
liberal
woke white people are pretending it's
not a thing when it is white people
when it is
and like
um social justice black warriors okay
they pretend that ain't nothing either
okay people who are trying to push black
narrative forward
wouldn't accept the black man's time as
a real fight okay it is
i know he is tired of it
i'm tired of it i know it i refuse to
just accept that it's a thing yeah
there's nothing i can do about it
because i realize either this is the
statement
i realized the other day for the first
time
there's nothing you can do
to argue a shrug
you struggle you're you are a culprit
for it okay this is part of your culture
okay clearly okay hit me right there
stuff there's times when me and you have
argued and when you lose an argument
your
your go-to
is rather than saying you know what
you're right i'm wrong
your usual go-to is
you shrug he said what do you want me to
do or what do you want me to say yeah
and there's nothing i can say to that it
that is the whole thing
that's the whole thing we could go back
and forth yeah but this look at that
and your blocks kiss your teeth
and you'll move on
you'll move on
and that is such a black tick it's
ridiculous bro the other my barber does
it mm-hmm
constantly
constantly bro i'll book an appointment
so this is the thing with my bubba i've
known about my bible all the time yeah
obviously i've been seeing donnie since
i was 14 yeah
so i booked online he's got a app or
whatever yeah um so i book online my
appointments online so if i book an
appointment for 11
i'll get there at 10 55
i want to make sure that if i'm if i'm
five minutes late i'm assuming someone's
jumping in my spot yeah so i'll get
there five minutes early and i'll sit
and i'll wait donnie's not even in the
building half the time mm-hmm don't even
if i'm the first appointment i know he's
not gonna be in the building
i know he's not gonna be in the building
that would drive me insane bro and i sit
there and i wait and i wait and i wait
oh the shop's open the shop's open all
the other barbers are there my guy rocks
because he owns a shop
i remember he [ __ ] fancies so i'll be
sitting in that back room
yeah yeah i remember i'm twiddling
fingers
and i'll chat to the my man
his name is iman like the second in
command his name is iman i'm like yo
iman
is jim is he here is that
no where is he i don't know
fam sometimes if he's feeling courteous
i'll get a phone call
yeah i'm just running late so this is
the other day yeah
the other day
i booked an appointment for
10 o'clock i think yeah
a rock up there
just as that note as i'm in the car on
the way there he rings me and says ah
i'm in coventry
i'm leaving now what time was this
like
no justin was about to leave my house so
my appointment was at 10 he must have
rang me at like
half nine
so i'm in coventry i'm leaving now so
i'm gonna be about 15 minutes late now i
know it is actually a 45 minute drive
but he sounded tired so i bet he just
woke up you ain't leaving now yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay i was thinking
where's this black man time going to
come into play yeah we'll get real we'll
circle round two yeah okay let's see
let's say it's 45 and i'll be about 15
minutes late and i said cool thanks for
telling me because i was just about to
leave my yard i'll leave a bit later and
he was like cool
so
i get there i'm sitting on my car and i
was like it's like 10 more minutes until
his 15-minute period
so it's like um 10.05 now
he's to be my appointment was at 10 it's
10 05 now and my car is now supposed to
be at 10 15.
i get another call at 10 15
saying uh him bringing me like are you
in the shop
i said no i'm just in my car outside the
shop he said cool
he has another barber shop in kettering
which is like
20 minutes from where we're at okay
and he's further up from you further
right it's closer to coventry
so he has to drive past this town okay
he said i just need to run into my other
shop i mean ketchup just needs to run
into our other shop and sort some stuff
out and then i'll be with you so i'm
gonna be a bit later than your 15
minutes i said i know that because it's
the 15 minutes now yeah and you're 20
minutes away if you're still driving if
you're still driving at 70 you're gonna
be 20 minutes from now you're saying
you're going to stop off at a shop
shout out and then vomit 72 yeah we're
talking another half an hour 45 minutes
minimum if you're rushing yeah
family rocks up i just get in the shop i
i give it like another 10 15 minutes
i'll go in the shop and i'll sit there
and wait he rocks up when he wants no
apology
nothing i said cool you good i said yeah
you he's that can't complain sit down
whips the thing out take round one
and i'm like
where's the apology what's this
what is this and bearing in mind to book
an appointment you have to pay more i
can imagine of course you have to pay
five pound more normal cut is
like 14 13 14. 18 is for a books cut
yeah
he'll still take you 18 pounds
yeah he'll still take your 18 pound
happily and i've beefed him about it
before
well what has he said what's his report
his rebuttal is
even if i'm late you're still first in
the seat
that's his rebuttal if i'm late and
there's 10 man lined up here if five of
them before you five of them after you
that's what your five pound is when i
get here you're in that's his
justification i'm like nah nah nah
so that
i can manage my day around yes of course
i can't sit here for an hour yeah like
it's not literally not about you it's
about me yeah that's my example because
of you yeah i book it because i've got
[ __ ] to do yeah so i think oh cool i've
got ten o'clock three ten to ten forty
five that's a nice 45 minute period
where i can get my hair cut let's book
that in so i know i've got it
he says yeah
it's just family shrugs he gives me that
classic shrug and i says
what do you want to do
you know what it is you've been coming
in for years you know what it is and i'm
like yeah but it shouldn't be that
amazing
what do you want me to do
and i'll just get vex i'll just leave it
same thing happened when i ordered
carabine the other day okay
fam
so there's a caribbean the caribbean
don't
uh deliver to my yard okay so i had to
go to my mum's yard which is 50 there's
a caribbean there my mom's always like
so caribbean at my mum's
near my mom's ordered it to my mom's
let's say it's supposed to be there at
six
it said it's going to be there between 6
30 i ordered it at half five they said
it's going to be there between half 6
and 6 45
i couldn't be bothered to ring or text
my mom and say i've ordered food to your
yard if it gets there just wait for me
so i'm just gonna get in the car now and
go so let me get there for half six
just in case they're they're early
fam i get their half six
6 45 comes and goes
seven o'clock comes and goes
7 15 comes and goes i get a message from
justi
enjoy your food these my fingers
delivered
no
these my fingers delivered
no
enjoy your food i'll be i'll be i'll be
looking outside
where is it where is it 7 15 comes and
goes half seven
half seven i get a knock on the door
no apology no nothing
man just said you alright i said are you
alright
where have you been fam where you been i
took the bag expected it to be ice cold
thinking he's been running errands
the thing was steaming hot so i'm
thinking you've just made this i ordered
it two hours ago and it's piping hot
obviously i want my food to be piping
hot yeah but i don't know what i'm what
yeah i don't know if i should because
like if it's cold i'm assuming you have
bear deliveries you've got backtracks
you've got whatever whatever and you're
making it to me now that's why you're
late but if it's piping hot that means i
ordered it two hours ago you've only
just cooked it now the shop is five
minutes from here
so you didn't have to drive far so it's
piping not you came from straight from
the shop to here that's how hot it was
came straight from the shop to here what
were you doing for the last two hours
what were you doing and i know it's not
a popular caribbean spot bro it's not a
popular caribbean spot
it's kind of popular yeah but not really
they ain't got a cure at the door this
is the spot we went to when i back in
the day when i came to yours no it's a
different spot
um
but yeah man gave me the bag gave me a
shrug and walked off and i was just like
there's nothing i can do or say
there's nothing i can do or say
i mean you could have said something you
could have been like why you took ages
the thing said enjoy your food he says 6
30 6 45. i know you're not a
confrontational person
when it comes to the thing well i run it
through in my head
before it even got there i already ran
scenarios
in my head
and i imagined me going through it
and these yardy man they don't care
about you like that so i would have
beefed him i already know how i would
have gone i would have beefed him and be
like big man what time did you call this
a man would have said dinner time
saturn like that in it something snarky
no like big man you said between hearts
between half 6 and 6 45 that's what
you're supposed to be here now you're
rocking up a half seven yeah
man would have said what would you want
me to do about it
i would have said i don't know i was on
compensation
mom said do you want a refund because i
can take the food back
i mean that's what these men are about
you're not getting your money back if
you're getting your money back i can get
my food get my food back yeah it would
have just been a pointless
i would just [ __ ] you know [ __ ] off
and i said you know what
these men don't care about return
customers like that they don't care
about return customers like that i would
have been like big man that's it like
i'm not running like you won't see my
business again
i care i don't care he would have
whispered it i don't care
from the sounds of it i don't want your
business again yeah this is the grief
i'm gonna get after i've delivered your
plan after i just delivered your banging
food then maybe i don't want your
customer again
so yeah i know what you're doing no no i
know how to beef scope oh that's jokes
and it's it's it's a consistent trait
throughout bro any black business
this is this is this is the thing
like not necessarily any black business
but like
any caribbean shop or any barbers
punctuality is just punctuality is
whenever you want yeah yeah yeah yeah i
hear you i do
guys just taking a quick break to let
you know what's popping over at
manscape hq
so the the mad
scientists they gave you the generation
one
and everyone was gassed they said nah we
can do better generation they're on our
iphone thing generation two we can do
better generation three that's when we
came on board yeah that's when we
thought okay yeah this is like this is
the pinnacle pinnacle the main male
grooming now this is why they got them
two million males gasps
they went back and said
yeah bear with us
there's more to come we've got more yeah
there's more to come we said what
next thing i know
hermes delivery driver
here generation four hold that let me
see what is this this is assistant fam
the rpms
the led light
bro then i messed it up there's knick
knack paddy wack so thing of the past
bro
manscaped
performance package 4.0 guys
level up level up that's that's all we
need to say isn't it level up level up
manscape.com the code is sng 20 off
and free shipping worldwide if you want
to get involved
get involved if you don't want to that's
your business that's your cell liberty
johnny that's your sellability your
celibacy that's your celibacy it is um
yeah if you do want to get involved
manscape.com performance package 4.0
it's a fourth generation the mad
scientist went off
code is s g 20 off free shipping
worldwide thank you for listening let's
get back to the episode another vlog
sorry bro
it's yeah it is what it is i've grown up
with it this is
part of life i just i just wish there
was something i could say to be like big
man it shouldn't this shouldn't be that
way but then that's what i'm saying
about the shrug it's the ultimate weapon
true because you can so you give him
everything bro you shouldn't be like
this you if you want to run a successful
business you'd be on time you should be
doing it and i have to just
what do you want from me i actually
don't know
i don't know i want you to do better for
you
i'm not just leave me alone i don't even
know you leave me alone if you don't
want to order it again don't order it
again say my barber he knows i'm never
going anywhere else yeah yeah so you can
win jamon all you want shut up
two hours later i'm stuffing the two
yeah we're gonna run my errands when i
know you're booked in because you can
whine and whine and wipe
you coming back you're still gonna sit
in that chair so shut up oh bro it's it
just reminds me of hospitality so much
like in general like the barber thing in
general
bro there's so many i remember back in
the day in what is when i was working at
grill on the market
um
back then i think mondays to
thursdays if you had like a black card
you'd get 50 off
food okay but there are some certain
items you can get food off yeah yeah
something like that um and i think maybe
this guy forgot his black card one day
or something i said i don't have my card
but i'm a member running my 50 percent i
was like oh 25 i can't remember what the
discount was and he was like i remember
i dealt with it i was like if you
haven't got a card i can't give you the
thing how am i meant to know yeah yeah
it was like he was getting so annoyed i
just ran me the discount i mean this
camper were right because i
i was like i'm not doing it i'm just not
doing it yeah and he said
all right cool you're who i think was
with him and like two or three other
people i remember we were sat
specifically with 53 oh no
table 53 prick he was like i'm never
coming back here you would never see my
business again blah blah blah i'm
thinking
why do people like to use that as a big
bear in mind i saw him next week yeah he
came in next week if he's actually a
member
do you know what i mean like people like
to use that empty threat like oh you're
never going to see my business again i'm
never coming back here blah blah
regardless of the shitty experience
you've had in certain restaurants that
you go to
repetitively and repeatedly you're
always going to come back regardless of
what you say
unless i've spat on you yeah unless like
there's a thing like people deep down
regardless of how much of a fuss they
kick up they know whether they're in the
wrong or the right
i can kick up the most think if i ain't
got the card and all you're telling me
is you ain't got the card that's it
then i'm gonna come back because i know
deep down i'm in the rock exactly i know
deep down i should have bought the card
that's my business
i wish sometimes i could speak
my thoughts some when guests speak to me
like they would
their eyes would would widen when i
speak the truth to them fam
there is a um
a client i train okay
um
and he's really nice and really cool but
he has really
strong political opinions and stuff okay
and he's not shy about spreading it okay
and he comes he goes for the throat when
he says stuff
and
i get annoyed because i know with the
heat that he comes with
if i was to speak my mind it would be a
confrontation and obviously i'm in a
place of business i can't have a
confrontation with you yeah of course
yeah yeah but i would like to not even
like in a confrontation it's just like a
debate a debate
a
like a healthy nice political debate i
can't have that with you because
you pay the business that i currently
work for money and i can't have that
because it comes back around if you get
offended if i say in my mind or you get
offended or anything like that
i'm out call on you yeah yeah it's done
it's gonna it's my head but sometimes he
goes off on a rant and i just literally
just sit there and think i just wish we
could have a chat outside of here so i
could just run my mouth to you run my
because i know your eyes will ride yeah
sometimes i think he must think i'm a
[ __ ] idiot because i sit there like
oh is it oh really yeah oh i didn't know
that yeah yeah and he goes off and you
can tell that fuels him when i say stuff
like oh that's interesting oh i didn't
know that
oh that's interesting
he gets gassed off
this and this and this and this i don't
want to be like shut up bro that's not
true because this this this and this and
this tell me something come on ah
but not even in like a rude way i don't
know
if you want to talk about it let's talk
about it because you're missing out more
than you think yeah but you must think
i'm a [ __ ] idiot
wait this is what it is game is the game
the game is the game man um
but um we're gonna say oh snap that's
what i was gonna say
before i forget
pause guys
pause the
pause the thing and listen to what i
have to say
every time you say that it never makes
sense they can't browse at a list of
what you have to say october 10th
october 10th
if you didn't know by now you've been
living in a hole but october 10th
london i don't know what the address is
but we'll put the address on the ting
october 10th london
somewhere in london
pbe podcast festival yeah bbe podcast
festival your boys are going to be there
it's our first live show people harass
us constantly yeah about finally doing a
live show yeah granted if you live in
south africa sorry there's not much i
can do about it sorry guys
um
but
if you can make it
how long is that it's enough time if you
live in a different country it's enough
time to get over here serve your
quarantine period
and come to the show yeah it's enough
time for that so book your flights now
um as i say guys what i'll add the
address to this bottom of the screen
here and uh yeah man show some love for
your boys yeah um
uh oh what's the
i remember what the website is called
now
bbe
podcast and agency
nothing something like that we'll throw
it on there as well
i'm not even going to try it but throw
it on everywhere the websites did i say
bbc no you said bbe i was gonna say yeah
um
website is in the description website is
probably on the screen maybe i don't
know
um
and
tickets grab your tickets show some love
your boys are gonna be on nine nine i
think we're the last one we're the last
one are we headlining i don't want to
put words in your mouth
but but typically the way these things
go
is you saved the best for last you know
typically when you go to wireless when
you go to a festival
who's lost fam the headliner fam beyonce
rocks up last she rocks up when she
wants how she wants bro
she has an hour set
that's all i'm saying is when you go to
the live shows
you kevin hart doesn't put on his red
cup boys
do his whole set and then throw on the
last red cup boy to finish it it doesn't
work it doesn't work like that
if you want the standing o you put the
big boys last
if you want to keep the crowd wanting
more you kept the big boys last
i'm just like i said i'm not putting
words in anyone's mouth yeah it could
just been a coincidence that's the way
it lined up
um
do we get more downloads than everyone
else on the lineup i don't know
i don't know
it's possible it's clearly possible
you know but hey
are we 21 in the podcast comedy chance
in the whole country
maybe
at least for spotify the biggest audio
platform on the planet according to them
according to them we're doing a bit
we're doing a bit yeah do we stay viable
on tick tock yeah from time to time
we chop up a little something something
and people going
they eat it all up
kick kick
that's hilarious
from time to time your boys stay viral
so
would it be the dumbest idea to have
these guys
close out the podcast festival no it
wouldn't be crazy you wouldn't be crazy
it's not the dumbest idea in the world
but guys show some love
we want to see sng everywhere everywhere
we want to go in the ting at seven
o'clock someone's kicking up a fuss
where's streets and giggs where's james
this thing's locked obviously billboards
yeah i want to see billy
obviously we want to show support to all
the other podcasts on the team i'm
excited to meet in everyone that's going
to show faces as well um but yeah guys
if you want to show up show some love
obviously we're going to be doing a meet
and greet thing afterwards for sure so
come on down to london come on down to
the show buy your ticket now before it
sells out um because i think those early
birds went back bad birds went
and went yeah early birds came away
jumping now that's why i had to get this
on this episode
come on down to the the festival um show
some love meet us greet us
bring presents if you're feeling fancy
um i don't know i won't say no yeah um
and yeah
that's it i've got a question for you
very controversial that's not i wouldn't
say a very controversial question but i
think it's a thinker and bear with me
whilst i ask you this question
okay so is it gay oh god [ __ ] sake
is it gay
if a transsexual
man that's transcended or trans
transcended what's the word i'm looking
for transitioned transition sorry not
transition yeah transitioned from a man
to a woman but still has their dick
okay and tease well they've got t's but
they still have their dick okay
is it gay if a trans transsexual man to
a woman transgender a trend what do i
say transgender is it gay if a
transgender man
to a woman
[ __ ]
a woman
but you find that attractive
i find it attractive not necessarily you
but as a human being like do you feel
like do you think that's gay so
let's see
porn for example okay so i'm watching
porn yeah
there is
a transgender
woman woman yes
having intercourse with a woman
with a biological woman a biological
woman
with their um
birthed penis yes
why would that
there's no
like not necessarily is it gay but like
is it well it might be more of a
question if i was a woman watching it
because then we've got a transgender
woman having sex with a biological woman
if we've got a transgender
like
i'm not gay because in
as far as pronouns are concerned
that's
lesbian porn true
so i'm just watching lesbian i watch
lesbian porn all the time
so no i don't feel like i'm gay for
watching lesbian porn
so it has to be the opposite way around
it would have to be
a
transgender woman
who
is having sex with a biological man
okay
so i'm watching
a former biological man have sex with a
current biological man
but that um
the first former biological man has now
transitioned to be a woman yeah
so they're a woman now yeah that makes
sense so that's heterozygous yeah so as
uh um as far as today's society is
concerned it's had to work it's hetero
yeah
so
i'm just going to throw this out here
i'm just going to throw it out i'm
listening to you i'm waiting for you to
say so fam
your boy was on pornhub the other day
don't get carried
away your boy wasn't pulling up the
other day yeah scrolling through the
thumbnails
scrolling through something else right
hear me out don't jump to the conclusion
i'm just preparing you in it that's why
i said she's rolling through the
yeah yeah yeah yeah as i'm scrolling
through you know if you hover the cursor
rover gives you a little preview little
snapshots we all know what it does
um
so as i'm scrolling through like
probably like a few weeks maybe a month
ago maybe two months i can't even
remember to be fair as i'm scrolling
through
i hovered my cursor over i didn't even
read the title
hover my cursor over
and there's
um
a black chick
sucking the skin
out of this dude yeah in these little
little clips yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
just
bare throat action
did i click on the video no okay but as
i'm going through yeah it's like i see a
glimpse of saturn in there
of like some phallus i see sutton [ __ ]
up and i was like
yeah
on the black tig yeah
and look at the title first thing it
says capitals transgender
now did i go yuck yuck yeah
no no
finally
was i turned on no but did i go yuck
yuck
same thing
um again cursive thing where you leave
the cursor running it shows the thing so
yeah yeah again it was that the pornhub
or
are you there's another website have you
heard of spank bank
nav spank no spank bang rather bank bang
i think so yeah with the g yeah
quality is it quality okay quality
remind me another time i think pornhub
is
because it's you you know i'm staying
solo tonight remind me tonight actually
remind me tonight
go on sorry it's a revive
sorry go on go and go on
i've got an empty apartment on myself
tonight that's hilarious it's a strange
strange location fam so okay um hovering
over the
hovering over the clip page um the clip
of the vid rather
and i see one guy just i see the fattest
ass
and one anal right just absolutely
slamming in different positions again
same thing happens like the fourth or
fifth clip later i see balls from the
back yeah yeah you're thinking
but how is this possible you know how is
again same thing you know when
everyone's like you're scrolling through
but you don't look at the names you're
just seeing images yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
titles there's bear ties i don't care
about the titles
yeah
and i see that because the first one was
the first still
was just a fat bag yeah i was like
you're intrigued i'm intrigued you know
yeah and then i see the balls of how is
this possible bro you sucked me in like
this bro
let me ask you now did you say yuck yuck
i don't think i did but i didn't click
it obviously you did click you kept
describing it but you didn't go ugh it
didn't make me nah i didn't because i've
gone through
and obviously these men are supposed to
to be fair i usually watch porn
incognito i don't know i'm just curious
i'm not curious but i'm just i'm just i
don't know i've always have since i was
a kid yeah so i think it's teenagers
like yeah yeah it's just fun
running about repetitive nature yes i've
always run porn incognito
um so
you like obviously these men are
supposed to recommend you things yes
because i'm running an incognito other
time there's nothing for them to
recommend it doesn't copy the cache yeah
yeah so there's been times where i've
been on the home page and there's man on
man
there's prayers on breastfeeding and i
scroll it's not the whole page but i'll
scroll past one a line yeah and that
does make me go uh yeah yeah yeah and
then it'll just keep moving
but that thing
that i saw the transgender thing i
didn't jump out
i saw the balls i said what's that
waited for the next one definitely saw
it again and i was like that's
definitely transgender so the title oh
it's transgender
but i still remember the suck suck that
i saw
i'm never gonna click on it but the
sucks suck i'm not judging anyone who
did i know what you mean because i know
i'm not the only one who saw that it's
got millions of views i'm not the only
one yeah yeah yeah no one looks at
titles i'm not the only one that saw the
first laptop and said hell yeah yeah
clicked on it
found out a few minutes in that's not
what you thought it was yeah yeah and
just kept it running yeah
that's hilarious that's
hilarious it is man hey man this is the
game we play
it's all a risk bro it's always a risk
it's always a risk um
right now what have you got
random
this is a leap a hop skip i had this
conversation with my mom the other day
it's a hop skip and a jump but i feel
it's justified
like so do you have you ever had like
friends or family members when you were
a kid that you just did not
get on with
probably yes but i can't really remember
i would like to say yes because i it's
inevitable but for the life of me i
don't remember
fam i think if you say something it
might trigger a memory when i was a kid
i had a cousin well step cuz my
stepdad's nephew yeah
his name was niall
and
i didn't check for my man okay for a few
reasons okay one
he just thought he was sick when he
wasn't okay
i was in year seven so probably like 11
12. he was in year seven as well yeah
eleven top at different schools and
stuff
so
he told me he could hoop
okay
he told me he could hope and i was like
gang we've got saturn in common
i had a basketball hoop in my back
garden we tried to hoop this fall was
trash like trash like never played
before trash and i was like i've been
lied to yeah starters why you would make
that up i don't know but it's whatever
he came to stay at our house for like a
week one time in the summer holidays
every day he did something to piss me
off
every single day he would take my [ __ ]
use my [ __ ] he was just disrespectful
bro he was just disrespectful
on the last night
i was
seething for this my man i was thinking
me and him are on the verge of scrapping
yeah
and one day he took my
psp remember psp yeah of course i
remember took my psp yeah and i said big
man run in my psp and i said you weren't
even using it because he was i was
sleeping on my bed we had a single bed i
remember and he was sleeping on the
mattress on the floor okay and the
sleeping bag was signed and i said run
me my psp bro you didn't ask me just
give it back playing it playing it in my
room in my face
and i was like big man you can't you
can't run your life like that yeah you
can't just be taking next man [ __ ] yeah
and expecting me to firm it yeah man
said sat in along the lines off i don't
know i don't put words in his mouth but
he said something along the lines of
shut up and deal with it he's something
like that to the point where i was like
nah fam i went to grips the psp off him
yeah and he yanked it and i fell off of
my bed onto his bed
as i've fallen off with tussling to give
me my psp i look to my left and i can
see under my bed yeah
random as hell
there were apple calls
apple cause
under my bed a whole week's worth
he this four been eating apples
and just putting them under my bed no
eating apples in bed couldn't bother to
go to the bin just rolling them under my
bed
seven
brown moldy ass apple cause stinking up
the joint under my bed
fam
we went for blows
i was thinking what kind of [ __ ]
sociopath that leaves apple cores onto
someone's bed and not even done that a
whole week's worth who does that fam
the other day obviously
my mum split up with my stepdad i lost
connection with all that side of the
family haven't spoken to him since all
this stuff all this stuff
mama sent me a news article the other
day because he still lives in luton okay
this is when we live in newton he saw
this in luton
see a picture of my man
looking raggedy okay it's a mug shot
thing
okay says
such and such wanted for attempted
murder okay mama said can you [ __ ]
believe it i was like yes i can yes i
can because he was a servant
was leaving apple calls under my bed
of course i can believe it
it was a starting point fam literally
when you see the starting points of like
a psychopath yeah of like well like
don't [ __ ] with cats and then things
like that who does that who starts like
torturing cats like who
leaves apple cause under someone's bed
for a whole week straight and it doesn't
say anything to anyone one thing just
gets the next apple the next day and
does the same thing
he knew he was going to get caught at
some point
he was just hoping it was after he left
yeah the psp got him in trouble he
didn't drop into psp
you wouldn't you would have been
bewildered the next time you had to
clean your room oh i thought i would
afford it with some paranormal activity
thing
if i'd left it because i couldn't look
under my bed yeah if i left it like four
five six days and i could just smell
some
and i look under my bed and it's just
bare apple cause your mum would have
killed you she would have gone mad she
would never believe it wasn't me that's
what i was gonna say your mom would
never believe it was you never believe
it wasn't me why the [ __ ] would i do
that should i i don't know but yeah you
tell me big man you did it who else did
that so soon she told me he's wanting to
attempt to murder i knew fam i was like
bang
all the puzzle fits now
the puzzle [ __ ] fits that's wild when
you said mug shot it reminded me of
something i saw on instagram not too
long ago
um let me see if i can find it i think
it was on i'm just bait um
it was about a mug shot obviously
yes
so
a man has been jailed for raping two
other men who he met on a date and up do
you see that he's got like the shitlocks
yeah yeah you read it i didn't read it i
just saw that and thought jesus fab well
what one i saw i read that was one for
jesus christ you know the men at the
same time
let me read let me yeah read the tape
so a man from a man from north london
who raped two men he met on a dating app
has been jailed for 14 years
aaron goody 23 of tramway avenue enfield
was sentenced at wood green court on
friday 17th he was found guilty of three
counts of rape two counts of robbery and
one count of blackmail
at the same court on monday the 19th of
july the court heard how good he was
arrested in july 2020 following an
investigation
sorry into two incidents where men were
raped by a man they had met on grindr
he then took he then took the victims to
a cash point and forced him withdraw
money while threatening further violence
both attacks had been taken place in the
enfield area
further inquiries resulted in goody
being linked into a third offense that
occurred in lambeth in january 2020
where a man was assaulted and forced to
withdraw money by a man who had who he
had met for consensual sex
forensic evidence taken from the victim
of the first offense led to scientists
identifying goody as the potential
suspect
officers carried out a further inquiry
including review cctv footage of phone
work which linked him to the three other
events that had happened
he denied any involvement but the
evidence collected by the scientists and
officers was overwhelmed and led him to
prosecution and the charges were placed
against him
family
can you imagine let's say we're on
grindr now let's say we're both gay
right mm-hmm
we're on grindr app we're trying to find
the next beat the next sweet thing yeah
yeah yeah cheeks that's all we want
cheese soft cheeks soft cheeks yeah we
match now we swipe swipes while we match
i mean this bruh
consensual sex it happens but he's a bit
forceful ah he's a bit it's like um yeah
yeah
what's that show we watched yeah um she
won an emmy for it by the way michaela
coleman
so this morning i will destroy you i may
destroy it yeah i may just throw you
[ __ ] great if you've never seen it
guys bbc it's probably on bbc i play
still i don't think it's on netflix
called i made the show michaela cole
greatest one of the greatest shows great
show great show anyway um
yeah man's a bit forceful like the
nightmare on destroying he slams the
door you're not going anywhere stop
you're not going and he's big
you're not going anywhere look i'm i
made it for you wow
so it forces it on you fam after that
after he busted his now you're just
there shaking
shaky you're trying to get your gums on
like you're trying
you're one of them gay guys that wears a
wears a vest and then where's the shirt
on top so you're just shaking yeah yeah
shaking shaking putting your shorts and
then your long sleeves your long socks
on their crepes on as you're about to
leave that no no let's go cash point
you're like now let's go for what
and now let's go cash point oh no he's
not no he says oh let me walk you out
it's like no no i'm good big man let me
walk you out i'm walking you out i'm
walking i'm walking i'm walking you out
are you like
okay
and you walk in let's say you didn't
drive you you take a bus you walk to the
nearest bus stop i'm okay no no let's
keep walking i'll walk you further it's
dark now i'll walk you further you see a
pack you see a cash board right again
get some money out real quick like what
get some money out real quick
would you what do you mean a big man
take your wallet out and get some money
out real quick i need that
i want to hold that get that atm maximum
i want to hold that
family
and my ass is still sore still sore
you're holding it like this you're
holding your back like that that
not to give him any praise yeah that's a
clever move
because he's already asserted dominance
if my
hole is still burning sore from the
pounding that my man just gave me
i mean no i haven't got the strength to
fight him i've got a leg to stand up
i'll just do what he says i just want
this situation over with i've got no
fight in me i want to be free yeah i've
got just take the p
i don't care bro just take the p i will
launch in my card from the first place
let's go ate it take the card take the
card there's the pin
i can't be asked
i can't be asked for it jerome
i can't be asked for it jerome
oh
bro
nah
it's not on it's not it's literally not
on it's not don't do that
and the thing is as well he must have a
mad like
power kink
these men that were down for consent it
was consensual sex they met up to bang
and he said nah like i it needs to be
non-consensual
i need to be i need to assert
that much dominance that you think
you need to am i even on ground yeah you
need to not want to be here anymore
nope
and he had the audacity say let's go atm
after let's go let's go cash point nah
you've cashed in all your chips
let's go cash points fam you've cashed
in all your chips for the day leave me
be have i not been through enough bro
oh i wouldn't know what to do i wouldn't
know what that's like experience
actually wouldn't know what to do i i
read i saw the picture and i saw the
title i did not read into it
because i saw the rape bit and i was the
thing that i threw is when i saw his
face i didn't assume
he would be raping men i just looked at
him and just thought he's a rapist you
know when he said two men i was like
then i read into it he's like and he's
taking money from them he's taking them
to the cash flow and say run me some
years he didn't even look stacked around
he does it but he doesn't look like he
can he looks like a road man though he
does look like a roman but he doesn't
look like he can instill that kind of
fear in another man he couldn't steal
that in me do you know what i mean oh
drapes his hair yank him bam as soon as
he tries this thing oh yeah
smack it you get off of me
get off me that's why i was perplexed
yeah he doesn't look like that kind of
person yeah yeah yeah he looks like a
sweet boy he looks like what the yeah
he looks like a face down ourselves he
looks like the tail six and yeah yeah
yeah yeah little bottom thing
he could never yeah
he must have draws a blade
he must have drew for a blade
100 he musta drew for a blade
oh do you know what that reminded me of
when he's sitting through a blade the
first episode of rick and morty season
one episode one
um
morty has this random bully he's only in
it for that episode yeah he dies um he
has a random ass bully
and i think they bump into each other by
mistake
and he's like oh my gosh like you know
he's always shy oh my god i'm so i'm so
sorry
and he said oh i didn't see you there
it's something like that and he grabbed
he grabbed morty by
the scruff of his neck and pushed him on
the locker he's like what are you saying
i'm poor what are you saying i can't
afford things and he grabbed the
switchblade yeah
yeah it's like this are you saying i'm
poor throwing up tonight i'm killing you
nah
that was shaken that's escalation
escalated i wouldn't know what to do
in school high school i'll pause grab
the switchblade like this no one could
flip and switch made in my facebook i
said i'm going to kill you
nah oh what are you saying i'm poor you
were slumped he'd be picking he'll be
holding me
my whole weight will slump on it ah
i couldn't believe it episode one you
know i couldn't believe it nah that's
true oh then rick comes in and saves the
day yeah rick always comes to save today
just freezes him on the spot bro rick
doesn't play those kind of games [ __ ]
hilarious um oh my god let's do it
let's bro oh this one's so petty that i
have to read it all right hit me this is
like super petty
cool so
am i the [ __ ]
me and my ex were dating for eight
months through lockdowns in australia we
were doing well and seeing each other a
lot but then she got suss and looked
through my phone
all she found was me liking other girls
photos and following the famous girls
okay i then looked through hers with her
permission and found the exact same
thing okay i didn't care because she's
mine but she felt disrespected
i unfollowed them and she unfollowed
them okay because it wouldn't be fair if
she didn't then a month later she checks
again and finds me liking girls photos
standards
she says it is too toxic and i wasn't in
this relationship for the long run and
went out
but she did the exact same thing
then a week after we broke up i found
out whilst i was playing my basketball
game this was around the six month mark
um
she said she wanted to go on love island
to my family friend
he hasn't even asked what the [ __ ] is
i'm assuming he's asking if he's the
[ __ ] for liking the girls picks and
stuff
um
so recap i was gonna say is that the end
of it yeah it's literally the end of it
okay right recap
with a girl for eight months
she goes for a phone and cece's been
liking tanks yeah following things yeah
he goes through her phone she's been
liking things following things say same
same same same yeah he unfollows them
she unfollows them yeah a few months
later
same thing she goes through his phone
he's been liking tings
she says you know what you're toxic
dumps him
then he's talking to his family friend
and the family's friend says you do know
she said to me a couple months ago that
she wanted to come on love island
all of that
that's dumb man i think it's clear that
they're young
aren't they just it's clear that they're
young they're like 21.
i'm saying like 15 16.
well that's [ __ ]
it's
like oh
[ __ ] like that is such pointless topics
of conversation
um
obviously like you said he didn't ask if
he's the hustle for this or for that
because he didn't really um give a
climax to his scenario but i still feel
like
one
if she feels as if
him liking things the following things
is an issue obviously yes she did the
same thing they both agreed okay we're
mutually gonna follow unfollow these
things and not like anything boom
he did it again well x amount months
later he's only a human you know he's
only he's only human
that's something you would say he said
because he's facts i'm only human bro
yeah but what does that actually mean
that means i'm not subscribing to her
petty nurse because i'm actually not
yeah
but you do realize
doing that
i can still see the picture without
doing that if i know if this bothers my
girl
i don't need to do this
i can just i can look at the picture
even if he's wanking over every picture
he doesn't need to do that yeah i hear
you i do hear you i do hear you
but then i my argument with that is this
is what instagram is for liking what
instagram for i understand your concept
of you don't have to like it you can
just see it appreciate and scroll past
granted i completely highly agree
um
but it's also
double ended or double edged rather
because of the fact that she was doing
exactly the same thing as well that's
what i said that's why i wanted to
premise it and say i'm not subscribing
to her [ __ ] all i'm saying is i was just
talking about your only human thing i
know i know don't get me wrong i know
okay cool i don't know because i already
know that would have been my response
yeah yeah as far as
the whole situation goes she's doing it
my situation i would fam if
if she was my girlfriend and she went
through my phone without my permission
and found them liking pictures and
beefing about it move from me yeah it's
done before i even find out get away
from i don't care yeah about your like
you you're discriminate all about it
that's your own insecurity i don't
care bro i don't actually care because
it's a it's an app
it's literally an app and more time i've
showed you pictures bare times but like
oh you've liked this and you've like i
have no idea i don't remember liking it
yeah because no one pays attention to
[ __ ] that they're liking yeah
no one does that unless there's
difference between like
unless
you go on a specific girl's page
she lives local we've had this
conversation before yeah she lives local
she's around she's in the cheating range
she's in cheating range and you've liked
everything yeah from the day that you
followed her until now you've liked
every single post understand that that's
a bit sass understand that's a bit sassy
that's a game plan yeah that's a game
plan because i know for a fact not every
single one of those pictures even came
up on your timeline you've been checking
in yeah
that's different when you go when you
click the search thing and she's the
first name there
yeah there's no way she's piff enough
yeah
that every pic needs a like there's no
way that she's only uploading banging
back to back to back over however many
times um that everything needs a like so
that granted still get off my dick leave
me alone but you've got a bit of a case
i would have already binge you off
because you broke into my phone and went
through my [ __ ] so i've already been you
off
but you've got a point i was probably
trying to move to her yeah but yeah as
far as like are you liking this girl's
picture you're liking this
yeah
me and the other 41 978 people
what are we talking about here
and then on for me the flip side of it
is also he's just as petty is insecure
everyone wants to go on love island
yeah i don't you probably don't but in
terms of like
if you want wealth yeah no one wants to
go on love island time to
oh she's saying she wants to go on love
island it means she doesn't want to be
with me
big man do you think love is real she
wants to secure a bag do you think love
island's real my guy
she wants to be rich and famous and
that's the easiest way to do it that is
it
i've got nothing else to say
i mean it's not open and sharp i've got
nothing else to say it was it's um
like i said the first thing i said was
clearly it's clear that they're young it
goes without saying the young because
this is not an adult conversation yeah
it's not found it's really not a
conversation it's something you both
will get over
um don't dp that much the next girl you
meet probably won't even care about the
[ __ ] that you guys are talking about
right now so it's just i i don't know
what the [ __ ] question is but it's
it's yeah it's irrelevant it's it was a
such an irrelevant read yeah it was nice
to talk about for a little bit but yeah
sorry bro the whole thing was completely
stupid and irrelevant um and
bro
you let your girl break into your phone
once and she got away with it and then
you let her do it again nah bro
and then she let you feel like the bad
guy
she's invaded your privacy twice in a
row hasn't said sorry once there we go
there we go what are we doing here
that's the moral of the story that's
what you need to take from this bro and
that's the same thing as well like i'm
the same in terms of obviously who had
said his piece but like for me
if you were that concerned like to the
fact where you said you unfollowed all
these girls yeah that's long the fact
that the reason that's a thing in terms
of like the
you didn't have to double tap
my energy behind that is that like you
made such an effort to unfollow all
these people like you didn't turn to
your goal and say look this is pathetic
i'm not following anyone i'm not
stopping liking things i'm not having
this conversation if you turn to her and
did that then she hasn't got a leg to
stand or next time she greets you about
it yeah but the fact that you were like
you know what that's fair i'm gonna
unfollow these people you can unfollow
these people and then you went and did
it again
it's like you've already justified her
argument last time
so now you're asking for trouble this
time yeah you didn't have to like
yourself in that situation yeah you can
still scroll through the pics without
liking them bro if you're trying to bang
these girls you can just dm them you
don't need to be liking these girls pics
like what are you doing to yourself
you you literally made your bed
you put yourself you accepted her
argument
and then you reinforced it when you went
and did it again you should have locked
her off for the first time or even if
you weren't gonna lock after she's just
being stupid and you're not gonna
entertain this [ __ ] and she can do it
she's done it you've done it you could
have just been like look we're clearly
both doing it what the [ __ ] are we even
doing here what are we actually doing
here let's just carry on with our lives
if you're happy i'm happy let's just
move on
but yeah and then this whole love island
thing uh you're a joke fam no offense in
the nicest way possible being martin
you're a joke oh bless your joke sucks
bro we're gonna turn around to me
tomorrow and say i've got an audition
for love and i wouldn't bat an eye
i'd say you better win you better win so
you could secure this
you better win secure this bag asap bro
i'm trying to come up
you better win if you get kicked out on
week two or three don't chat to me
that's your business can't go if you're
gonna go for it go play to win yeah
secure this bag for us both yeah man
yeah man
but anyway guys yes that's it happy
monday thank you very much have a good
and and um patrons will see you on
thursday literally by where's that mouth
we'll see you on thursday come on right
love
[Music]